It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Pero on the brain is speaking a little bit fluffier than normal.
Today, Ruffians, we are your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you, Ruffians, for joining us for our 169th episode today!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
Ruffians, you look...
Maybe you should stay tuned then.
FUWAMOCO Peros?
No, we're not Peros!
We're FUWAMOCO!
I think it's...
If there's somebody else that it suits even better but... First, Ruffians!
For Ruffians joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Right now, FUWAMOCO Morning will be brought to you temporarily on Mondays once a week.
So that, you know, you can get more
Good job!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts to the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
Thank you for waking up and joining us today, Ruffians!
We're so happy!
Another big week's about to start and we're happy to start it off together with you!
FUWAMOCO!
Wow, there's a bunch of exciting things to talk about!
Moco-chan, a lot of news going on in hololive!
Let's check it all out!
Huh?
Moco-chan, Moco-chan, why are you getting all quiet again?
Pero?
Pero Sighting?
Ruffians, just because we're wearing the Pero cap... No!
Doesn't make it a Pero Sighting, you know?
No!
No... Yeah, it's just a hat, Ruffians!
It's just a hat!
Don't be silly!
Huh?
Three?
Three perros today, huh?
Are you seeing something?
Huh?
No.
I'm not Pero!
I'm Fuwawa!
I'm Mococo!
Ruffians, you understand this, right?
Right.
Basic common sense.
Use it!
FUWAMOCO-chan, why would you say that?
Well... Huh?
We don't have a Pero sighting, but...
There's something that happened, Ruffians.
Maybe we should talk about it.
Ruffians!
What happened here?
He took over a channel on his birthday.
I can't believe it.
Ruffians, why didn't you let us know right when it happened, huh?
Use the hashtag FUWAMOCO Morning when it's going on.
Why is Pero here, huh?
Do you see this?
Do you see what's on the screen here?
Something very nasty happened.
Very, very nasty.
In case you don't have the understanding of what this here on the left is.
That's okay, I don't mind.
Wow!
Pero.
He made a list of the whole EN members!
Not who he wants to kiss from the most.
Not who he wants to be kissed by.
Wait.
Not who he wants to
This doesn't matter!
It does matter!
Excuse me, it does matter!
I didn't pay attention.
Why am I the only one in F tier huh?
I mean I guess it's okay but you know it's never happy to be in a tier ranking and be in F tier.
Especially on your own.
Why is no one not with me?
It's okay.
I wish I was in F tier there with you Moco-chan right by your side.
Does that make you feel better?
Yeah.
Ruffians, this is disgusting!
Nasty!
Filthy!
Fuwawa should be an S!
I don't want to be an S!
F is for fuzzy, it's also for fluffy, no!
I don't wanna think about this.
No, you know, Ruffians, you've seen Pero's tongue before, right?
Yeah.
Right.
Nightmare fuel.
We understand, you know, it was his birthday.
Not acceptable.
Please don't let him get away with these things, okay?
Yeah.
I think this just means, Moco-chan, you know, every August 8th from now on we have to watch out.
August 8th?
Is it August 8th?
I can't remember.
I didn't think it was 9th.
So being remembered.
What day was it?
8th?
9th?
Ruffians, you remember, okay?
You remember!
Ruffians, I couldn't remember either or.
Maybe both days.
BAU BAU!
Watch out for him, okay?
Please remember the important things, Ruffians.
Extra, extra safety.
Got it?
He can't keep getting away with it!
I have to stop him.
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan!
Let's put that aside.
All the awful feelings aside.
Forgotten.
There were so many exciting things that happened throughout the month of August this month.
So fun!
And one big one was...
Justice!
They had their 3D debuts!
Starting with Elizabeth, and then we had Gigi!
And then Cecilia and Raora!
And then most recently they had their 3D collab All of Justice all together!
And we watched it together with all of Abyss!
It was something else!
You know, we got to see a lot of
Justice and, uh, why maybe?
We are still completely fine.
We are.
Good.
No worries.
No.
Justice does not stand a chance.
Yeah.
It's not like we were worried or anything.
It really solidified, you know, the fact that I am not concerned in the slightest.
I saw a lot of their skills, you know.
I had one question.
What?
And I was a bit confused.
Just this.
Just like that.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Justice.
Just like that.
Get that target.
What are you both saying?
We saw, did you see that one?
You know they had to type on a keyboard.
And that one I was like, oh I'm not gonna answer the super easy trivia questions.
I'm just gonna skip-a skip-a skip-a.
Yeah, just skip-a skip-a.
That's why we're here, you know.
Couldn't do easy things like just knock targets off of each other with a bat.
They couldn't even spin around in a circle properly.
What are they doing?
We can teach them how to spin.
Although...
Cecilia's good.
Very good at spinning to win.
Yeah, but she still loses.
Yeah, she lost.
Training time!
Yeah, I think, you know, we're feeling extra comfy.
Extra comfy.
But, you don't know!
Justice has made their 3D debuts.
They have a bunch of exciting merch and everything to commemorate the moment.
But amongst that, they have their 3D acrylic staff!
We really like the 3D acrylic stands because they are big!
See the FUWAMOCO too!
These are extra special!
Because you know, it sort of means that now you are a full-fledged hololive member.
You've been here, you've made your 3D debut, and now you know all the possibilities are there waiting for you, you know?
They're big!
They are big!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Congratulations Justice on your DD debuts!
Ruffians!
From FUWAMOCO, we have some very exciting news to share!
Recently, you know FUWAMOCO, we're kind of a little bit more in the magazines over the last few months.
But!
We're in one really big magazine, the FUWAMOCO!
We're in Comptique!
Comptique!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
FUWAMOCO
At one point we were calling it the 1,000 questions.
It felt like 1,000 questions!
I don't think I've ever answered this many questions at once.
And there's a really really heartwarming retrospective recap on our two years in hololive so far too.
And we have a really cute manga.
The manga too!
So cute!
And you know we also had an interview together with Patra Onee-chan.
You know we talked about Akihama, moe culture, nighttime showtime, a bunch of different things.
And there's also a little bit of some quality photos of FUWAMOCO too.
They're pretty cute.
Alright, Moco-chan.
So please check them out.
There's also, you know every magazine in Japan kinda likes to have bonuses.
What's a magazine without a bonus?
And this time there's a special bonus card.
A dress-up stand.
We have three outfits.
And a Pero might be included too.
By the way, also Paternone-chan, she had a special interview with Aqua Plus, one of our favorite game companies!
They make chihuahua and utawarerumono, and we love them!
And I'm definitely not envious on this one.
Definitely not.
Come on, Moco-chan, we're so close.
I wouldn't have been able to talk to them.
No, I wouldn't go anywhere.
I'd be like, I'm so happy!
It's an honor!
Hi!
But we hope, Ruffians, we hope you can get your paws on it.
We have heard that trying to order online seems like it's been so kind of popular.
So it's a little bit hard to get online.
So we hope, Ruffians, if you want to get your paws on it, please check it out.
I think there's also digital versions.
Maybe there will be more released online.
If you happen to be in Japan, there's a digital version.
No shipping!
BAU BAU!
But you know what?
We have a third concert, all for one, coming up later this week.
But something's very, very happy!
It's been announced!
Just the other day, hololive Indonesia, it was announced that they're having their very first in-person concert!
BAU BAU!
Congratulations!
So exciting!
It's gonna be happening at Comic Frontier 21 on November 15th and 16th!
Really soon!
Right!
But this concert is celebrating Whole ID's 5th anniversary and it's titled Chromatic Future.
Look at them here all so cool and sparkling!
I'm so excited!
It's huge!
Right!
We're so, so happy!
Yeah!
Really happy for all our ID's and fans!
We were really, really hoping, you know, maybe we'll... Oh, maybe we'll end up with a million!
Oh, right!
Maybe!
Oh, we're really, really happy.
Right, we were watching Karaoke on Cloud 2!
So... And you know, being able to see all the ID fans and reactions on Twitter and Twitch.
Yeah!
We really can't wait.
We're so excited.
I wonder what songs they're gonna be performing.
I'm so excited.
We'll have to look forward to it, but a big hug as the whole ID!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Maybe there's not so much hololive English news or hololive JP news or hololive ID news.
FUWAMOCO news, um, Moco-chan.
You wanted to share something that has been fun recently.
We talked about it a bit here and there and on Twitter.
And Ruffians, the next picture that's gonna be shared might have this.
Does have bugs.
If you don't like photos of bugs, maybe look away.
If you feel like your morning breakfast is not going to be as delicious as it is normally.
Okay!
Because recently... De-den!
It's open!
We took them home!
This is Cho-cho!
Cho-cho that we talked about previously!
Look at Cho-cho's so amazing body!
This is not the pervert Takeda!
Hi!
See, and look, we got a new- Are they alive?
No, they're dead.
See, and this cicada's different.
This is not Drainage Senpai's friend that we're gonna give her.
No, no.
This is a new one for FUWAMOCO.
Yeah.
And that's Chocho that we picked up- We found.
Outside the studio and then we thought maybe we could revive it and then we couldn't and then it was still dead by the time we left so we took it home.
Yeah.
Isn't Chocho beautiful?
Yeah!
Chocho was really big when it still could've half-alived.
Yeah.
And this is a new cicada!
Yeah!
We've been having, you know, cicadas, they only last for so long.
Yeah, they come out of the ground.
They shed their skin so you can pick up the shells and that's fun but you don't really see the dead cicadas that often.
But the story behind him is that one morning, we got up early and we're like, Nerissa, let's go have breakfast!
So we went to have breakfast.
It was delicious breakfast.
It was really, really rainy.
Yeah.
And then, when we went out of the restaurant, then Nerissa spotted a Cicada and she goes, FUWAMOCO!
It wasn't here when we went in, so then it's probably just recently died.
Why don't you bring it home?
So, you know, I took something special back from the restaurant with us.
Doggy bag.
And now we have our own cicada.
You know, the friend that we have for Ririni-senpai.
Oh, that's just the shell.
No, Moco-chan, that's the cicada.
It's just missing half of the body.
For Reine-senpai.
No, no, no, for Rui-ne-senpai.
You kept on saying Reine-senpai.
No, Rui-ne-senpai.
Ruffians!
But Reine-senpai also did get a special shell in the can.
See, we found a cicada that just happened to be shedding its shell.
Yes, I think we talked about it.
We did talk a little bit.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Yeah, we learned from the JP Ruffians!
You know when you think there's a dead cicada, you go, oh there's a dead cicada!
You maybe go and try and touch it or pick it up, and then it's like, NO I'M ALIVE!
You call that semi-final.
You know, cause in Japanese a cicada's called semi.
And then, it's kind of a pun because you think it's over, like it's done, but no, it's just semi-final.
Yeah.
I'm happy though!
Why do bugs go like my legs?
FUWAMOCO-chan's only bothered with bugs on your legs, huh?
Yeah.
I haven't had any other issues with bugs.
No.
Do you want to know where this Akira is sitting?
And where Chocho is sitting?
Chocho is actually sitting right beside our 3D acrylic stands!
He got dropped because the air conditioning blew him over so he lost his antenna.
And then the cicada is sitting on our kitchen counter.
At first he was in our, what's it, our bath area.
And we put the drying cycle on.
But now I think he's dry.
Next to your foot!
Not next to the food, but kind of in the...
He's on the opposite side of the microwave.
He's not near the microwave.
But he's more closer to the sink.
That is the food!
No, he's a pretty crispy thing.
He just did a good job at drying it, I think.
Don't eat the chopsticks!
I'll do my best!
But hopefully we can get some more cicadas before the summer ends.
Gotta keep your eyes open.
I always turn on my phone light being like... Cicada?
Is that a leaf on the ground or is that a cicada?
I think that's a cicada.
It sort of looks like a little cicada.
How many do you want?
As many as we can.
Why not more?
Yeah.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Not hate them, we eat them.
I don't hate them though.
But they're friendly, but I don't like them.
No.
Yeah.
Eat them.
BAU BAU!
You know, Ruffians are all complimenting her.
I can't stop smiling.
This is a good place to talk about this, yes.
As you know, Ruffians, I mentioned that there's somebody that looks even better at this.
Do you know who that is?
That's you, Ruffians!
Because we have... De-den!
Right now!
Ice Ticket Anniversary Celebration which is on sale!
BAU BAU BAU!
And you can get your own very... Your own very own...
Pero on the Brain Camp!
What is wrong with it all?
It was not sweaty.
Not stuffy.
Yeah.
Pero's always on your brain.
I can have Pero even more on the brain.
Now you can show your feelings.
Alright.
And also, you know, in the set, we have the FUWAMOCO Ita shirt!
It's a very cute FUWAMOCO shirt, you know.
What a lesson I've been to, buddies!
You don't really see merch like this that often.
This time, it's a very cool design.
Maybe not as fluffy and fuzzy as usual.
But I think it'll be very well paired together with the Happy Puppy Happy tune.
We'd love it if you wanted to wear it!
We also have the FUWAMOCO Donut Cushion!
One side is Fuwawa and one side is Mococo!
It's in the shape of a pondering.
It's rather big.
Rather big, you know, maybe you could use it as a pillow or just a nice big sofa cushion.
A decent sized sofa cushion, kind of.
Yes, very cute.
You can put it in your desk chair.
You know, very comfy to sit on too.
But if you want to, there are Ruffians so you can see Fuwawa and Moco-chan at the same time.
If you have a big sofa, I guess that will work.
You might want to get two.
And we also have a voice pack.
We're missing one, Moco-chan.
We also have a very special situational voice pack in English and Japanese.
Cat Cafe D with FUWAMOCO!
It's very cute.
And this one is also digitally available.
It is digitally available.
So you know if you're kinda like, ah, shipping and everything.
No, no, no.
And last but not least, we have our fluffy fuzzy adventure mat!
It's a desk mat, you know you can put it underneath your keyboard.
My first desk mat!
You have your table!
And the illustration is by Ikoi-sama!
Very very cute, so we hope you get your paws on it.
It is available, the pre-orders are only open for a limited time until the end of the month, so we hope you can get it.
Thank you Ruffians!
Bye bye!
You can have the perrocap too, Ruffians!
And speaking of second anniversary... Advent, we have some very exciting announcements!
I think Ruffians you might have heard, but there might be some Ruffians that haven't heard too!
Advent, we have a brand new original song!
Jonathan!
Ruffians!
I think there's been a number of Ruffians listening over and over.
Thank you so much!
Jonathan, you like it more?
Of course!
But it's very snazzy.
There's a lot going on in a good way.
You know, you love it!
FUWAMOCO!
I feel like Genesis and Rebellion, they go like kind of hand in hand.
But Genesis definitely shows our growth over the past two years.
So we're really happy.
The PV is so cool, the MV.
So we hope that you'll check that out too on the hololive English official channel.
But together with that, there is also
This was... Okay, yeah, there is also announced the story of Advent!
Yeah, what is this now?
Together with Genesis, it was announced that Advent, we're gonna be releasing a series of five original songs!
And it's the story of Advent.
Genesis being the first one, and then we have maybe some more coming up.
Do you remember the other song titles?
I don't know if Ruffians know that's the song titles.
So many!
You can't wait!
We are the Ruffians!
We're so so lucky!
We can't wait until you can hear them all!
So please reply to them!
And in the meantime we'll be really happy to listen to Genesis lots and lots of Ruffians!
Actually Genesis, we really like Genesis.
These songs are like morning.
Ruffians!
If you're like impatient, you wanna hear them now!
You'll have to wait!
BAU BAU!
And also it's our second anniversary!
It was announced that Advent, we're gonna be having our second anniversary live on the run!
We're on the run!
Yeah.
I don't know why we're on the run.
What are we worried about Moco-chan?
I don't know why.
Obviously justice is not much of a threat.
What are they doing?
Wow, time lag.
But we're gonna be having our 3D 2nd anniversary live on August 29th at 7pm PT.
So we hope that you'll be there to cheer for us, FUWAMOCO!
You know, even after all for one, there are still more to look forward to!
We'll continue to do our best so please cheer for Advent!
August is packed!
Yes!
It's gonna be a fun rest of the summer, so... Thank you, Advent!
BAU BAU!
And, um, I forgot one thing.
Give me a moment.
Moco-chan!
Yes!
Finally!
Coming up this weekend, we have hololive English's third concert all for one!
BAU BAU!
Oh yeah!
You haven't seen that yet, huh?
You haven't seen that
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
It's gonna be at Radio City Music Hall in New York!
Happening on August 23rd and 24th!
And right now, Ruffians!
There's streaming tickets available!
So please, if you haven't, please get your streaming tickets!
But!
If you know maybe you're feeling a little bit adventurous, you want a little bit more excitement this summer!
There's still some tickets available!
So we hope that you'll go check it out!
Maybe you can get your paws on some Radio City Music Hall!
Yes!
Radio City!
Sing it wrong?
Did I say it wrong?
I don't think so.
Radio Music City Hall!
Radio City Music Hall!
She can't even do her solo, it's okay.
How was it go?
A bouquet and a trip to New York right away!
Wow!
Amazing!
I know it's a little bit of a big hurdle but you know!
Especially for Ruffians!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
We can't wait!
FUWAMOCO I missed you!
Thank you Ruffians!
You know we made so many precious memories with Weeking Dimensions.
We can't wait, you know.
It's a very special snapshot in time.
So we can't wait for this special moment together, Ruffians.
BAU BAU!
Ah, the week has just started, Moco-chan!
And it's a big one, Ruffians!
Are you excited?
Maybe there's some things you're a little bit nervous about.
Especially if you're going to New York for the first time.
Or maybe you're just nervous because it's another week, huh?
Yeah.
Are you excited?
Oh, you're not nervous?
Yeah.
Well, maybe the Ruffians need to get pumped up a bit.
P-p-pumped up!
Yeah!
Let's get pumped up, Moco-chan!
Okay!
Ruffians!
It's that time again!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me!
Mococo!
Ruffians!
It's almost time!
For what?
Not school!
No!
Not another week week!
Forget about that, okay?
It's time!
For!
Everyone!
The big hololive EN concert!
You're ready, right?
No more taxes.
All for one!
Got it?
Yes!
Aliens!
What?
All for one!
Un!
You ready, right?
Yeah?
No?
It's okay.
Let's practice, okay?
Not to me.
Keep quiet.
All for one!
Yeah.
Fuwa!
Moco!
Let's get ready, okay?
Can you say the three magic words?
Along with me, okay?
Okay, here we go.
Three, two, one.
All for one!
Let's be excited for it and look forward to all... Look forward to it all week, okay?
Hopefully I don't trip on stage.
BAU BAU!
GANBATTE DE!
Are you gonna be okay, BAU MOCO-CHAN?
I messed up the pup talk.
Oh, then that means I won't mess up over one, right?
That's how it works.
BAU BAU!
Let's do our best, okay, BAU BAU?
Shall we take a look at...
Regular cornice.
Regular cornice!
Do you have a Doggie of the Day today, Moco-chan?
Let's look!
Our Doggie of the Day is... It's Kobe!
BAU BAU!
Kobe Kobe?
Kobe?
BAU BAU!
It's so cute!
Is that a pom-pom hat?
It's a pom-pom hat, Moco-chan!
He's so cute!
That's a good tongue.
There, you have ears that smile.
I think somebody knows it's their birthday.
You guys are so cute!
He's six years old.
Six years old doesn't look it.
He used to be so small, but look at him now!
He's kind of chunky.
Time flies when you have a loud barker.
Is that how it works?
How does Kobe BAU BAU?
Kobe birthday?
I think it's something like
That's cute, don't you know?
I think it's okay to be loud when you're so cute like that.
And hot.
We're even cuter, right?
Pom-pom hat accepted!
We don't know that either, right?
Yeah.
Not like we're wearing hats too.
BAU BAU!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday, Kobe.
Boy, today I went on a walk we haven't!
De-den!
That is a hike.
How high did you go up?
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
I'm going on a hike.
I want to match the mountain.
Just looking at this makes me want to go outside.
It's time for a walk!
Okay!
BAU BAU!
And the Question of the Day!
Today's Question of the Day is... De-den!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
Some days you might not be feeling the brightest.
Maybe you woke up on the wrong paw.
And I wanted to know, what do you like to do when that happens?
BAU BAU!
Well, you know... We're not humans, we're demon dogs, but you know...
We're just like everyone, we have good days and bad days, you know?
And you know just the other day?
We did not have a good day.
We woke up and we're like, okay, it's good and we're gonna do our best.
Confidence, yes!
We're preparing lots and lots.
Night before, very good.
All prepared, good good.
No.
But I think, you know, on those days when you're just like, this is not going well, it's a bad day.
You have to be kind to yourself.
You have to forgive yourself.
It just happens, you know?
So in any areas that you're like, okay, if I can do this, then that'll make things better.
Even just a little bit, do that, okay, Ruffians?
Give yourself a little bit more wiggle room.
A little bit more forgiveness.
I mean, you should forgive yourself all the time, you know?
None of us are perfect, you know?
We all have bad days.
But maybe on the days that just don't go right, just a little bit more kindness.
You know, FUWAMOCO, we're lucky because we have each other by our sides all the time too.
When we have a bad day, we don't have to say anything.
I know.
Moco-chan's having a bad day.
Don't even have to say it, it's just... We hope we can be there to make a bad day a little bit better for you.
If we could do that, that would be great.
That would make us really, really happy.
And hopefully more!
Today's gonna be a good day!
Good week!
No wrong paws, only the right paws.
Yeah.
Okay?
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
You know, FUWAMOCO Morning is temporarily once a week on Mondays.
But we're still looking for submissions!
Don't forget your submissions!
I see you there forgetting me.
I don't have this question, and now I forgot, but I wanted to ask it.
I'm so glad I have this really good walk, but there's this really good volume.
Oh, it might have been Pero.
Please submit with the hashtag FWMCMORNING.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
We make it together with you.
You don't know what to submit?
Submit!
We're waiting, okay?
BAU BAU!
And FUWAMOCO, we have another stream coming up right, Moco-chan.
We have De-den!
Today we're gonna be playing Okayunyumu!
Okayu-senpai recently had a visual novel game where you spend your life together with Okayu-senpai.
And the English version just came out and you know visual novels are kind of a thing.
So of course we're gonna be playing it.
We're gonna be playing it together with you, Ruffians, as far as we can!
And we're really excited.
You know we played all of... where are you from?
So now we get to experience Okayunyumu mode!
Ruffians, you know we mentioned the cheering space?
We'd really be happy if you cheered for us there too.
All for one.
After that, we're going to be going back to the Northwest Positive.
But during that period, we'll also be having shorts.
Some shorts that we worked very hard on being uploaded to our channel.
So we hope that you'll be checking back and checking those out.
Please look forward to them, okay?
Thank you, Ruffians!
And for Ruffians joining us on the archive today, your FUWAMOCO word is... BAU BAU open wide!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much Ruffians for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians!
FUWAMOCO!
I saw Huey.
BAU BAU!
Human Porn.
Kiko.
BAU BAU!
Senka.
Playing with Pup.
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!